Victor ortíz former WBC welterweight
champion you fought Floyd Mayweather
yeah actor dancer dancer bowtie wearer
yeah well let me just ask you an honest
question okay did you know that I was
gonna wear this tie you felt a little
insecure a little intimidated you were
like at the last second rapport
tied up I need to do something to sort
absolutely I had to man I was like well
it's gonna look really polished really
nice I have to step up the game rise to
the occasion okay I respect it yeah well
I appreciate you joining the Rich Eisen
show you look fantastic is two very very
uh well-dressed men maybe even GQ I
don't know we're here somewhere on a lot
of shoe cover shoot um listen there's
been so much discussion about this fight
Brock just referred to it as the fight
of the century I've heard that so many
times before in my life just heard that
also I think as a boxer you face Floyd
Mayweather
you're obviously a fan your participant
you're an actual fighter the fight of
the century
what can we expect Saturday night in all
series what do you expect to happen in
the first three rounds let's say that
possibility of the fight being done
seriously oh yeah
how Mayweather you can end it when he
wants I personally think in the sense of
does he have power I don't think so
does he have power to take care of
somebody of a pro debut caliber as a
boxer I think so do you think that well
if you're if you're coaching talking to
your best friends with Conor McGregor
yeah who's never fought a professional
boxing match who's going to get paid so
much more than he's ever gotten paid in
a UFC fight because even the face of the
UFC is not a very very wealthy guy when
it comes to athletic prowess which it
says something about the USC but if
you're best friends with Conor McGregor
and he says Vick what do you suggest I
do to put myself in the best position to
win this fight what would you say I
would tell them the pressure pretty much
pressure of the fight and don't don't
let the guy breathe but keep it keep it
clean obviously you know right
if you don't keep it clean isn't there
isn't there like they see there's a
contract there's a clause or something
like that so they say yeah so they say
allegedly allegedly you gotta say
allegedly about every allegedly okay god
we have to say allegedly preface it and
end things with allegedly I was
discussing earlier my disappointment as
a fan of the UFC with the continual
major fight of the century
two weeks later these guys coming dirty
with whatever they're using allegedly um
how many times his Floyd Mayweather been
tested for you know steroids illegal
eluc illegal substances before this
fight how many times did you guess he's
been tested I would say about twelve at
this point in time twelve the last two
months since actually since the fight
was announced which is approximately
about two months uh McGregor's been
tested ten okay I don't know where what
kind of issue that's gonna bring up but
it's interesting now I know you you're
you can't speak to the UFC side of it
but in this day and age can't they test
these guys I mean listen it would suck
it would suck for a lot of people
there's a lot of money on the line and
and and when you say that we're not
talking about you know a few thousand
bucks there's billions of dollars
probably at the end of the day on the
line if one of these guys Mayweather
McGregor or any fighter before a big
fight the week of a fight got tested
positive well let's just say
theoretically mayweather tested positive
today for they're not gonna they're not
gonna tell anybody today they have to
keep the train going
it's there's too much money in Vegas
there's too much money in UFC this war
there's too much money online that
trains going full-speed
he could have Tiger blood in him today
and they're gonna keep that fight and
then two weeks later they'll be like oh
he's a forty legally correct absolutely
so how do we fix this because i'm shy'
feel cheated about what happened in the
john jones thing and and i feel cheated
i mean it's not just boxing and UFC
obviously it's all over sports how do
you suggest they fix this if they really
wanted to get to the bottom of and make
sure we're having clean participants how
do we do this man how do we do that's
like that's a great question that's like
a million dollar question how do we fix
this i hey like you said a little bit
ago
the trains rolling you can't slow it
down can't stop it I think a rematch
with out any kind of you know issue of
dirtiness in it would definitely be on
the line that's my personal opinion
right because I mean obviously the
fights already here it's days away you
know the the the the big thing one of
the big things there's been so many
storylines and and and you know like
it's it's gaining momentum that people
are bored Mayweather agreed it seemed
like this was a Khmer weather thing he
agreed to fight in a town scrubs eight
ounce gloves Saturday night what does
that mean how much power is
differentiate between ten ounce gloves
which I think they were gonna use two
eight ounce gloves
does that give McGregor any advantage
does it give me whether any advantage
well certainly gives Mayweather an
advantage because that's the world he
comes up in McGregor he's never actually
fought in a an actual fight in the
senses of not a sparring match I'm
talking actual fight boxing
yeah with eight ounces or ten ounce
gloves cuz you know if you say an actual
fighting be like I thought UFC I'll kick
you I'll beat you up Victor he is a
fighter no I know but you know guys nuts
I'm a fan but it would threaten draymond
Green go ahead hey be careful what you
wish for you yeah so regardless I think
doesn't really matter what size the
glove is gonna be at the end of the day
it's gonna be skill I mean at the end of
day it's a pro debut ur Russia's a you
know a well veteran fighter you know I
think with that eight ounces it'll add
some power to the boxer and not to
lesser any on McGregor but twelve rounds
of eight ounces you're not used to that
now you said recently that you you had a
very crazy wacky I'm sure you look back
on that night that you fought him way
whether and you probably have so many
thoughts feelings um you know and just
like it was just such a crazy night and
I was rooting for you I've never rooted
for Floyd Mayweather in a fight I am
rooting for him Saturday because I am
rooting for the sport of boxing I'm
rooting for the boxing for the boxer but
what did you take away from your fight
with your four rounds with Mayweather I
recently you said you felt like he
didn't have a lot of power was
only four rounds and you you weren't as
impressed the hype of his speed didn't
live up to what that's what it comes
down to for me I mean I wasn't trying to
bash on everyone but people want to know
the truth and the honesty that I have
they don't agree with it but I have my
opinion and people in the world have
their opinion my opinion of that
particular night was I wasn't kind of
impressed to myself in the census of I
came in and the whole time it wasn't
Victor's got no speed victor has no
speed he has only power he carries the
the left and the right they're equally
he's strong getting at it but then when
I went into the actual fight I started
okay okay come on champ what do you got
oh yeah so right away I think the
awkwardness of me being lefty right
kinda like okay okay he's a little
ggressive the mo he went like that to me
I kind of moved he threw a straight
right I went over the top straight and
then hooked him if I'm the not that fast
and I'm the slowest guy in the world I
just carry power that how am I gonna do
that to the fastest man in the world
right it makes sense to me so what did
you take away from I mean I know it was
only four rounds it was it wasn't even
full four rounds very beatable yeah but
how come he hasn't been beaten uh not
sure because we don't have a rematch
right that's my opinion but mine a gun
upon many so so so so Conor McGregor is
gonna go after him he is also
left-handed he claims that he could
fight both ways we don't know what he
could do as far as boxing um
again you're thinking that the only way
the only chance in in heck that Conor
has is to like do what Maidana did
because when you watch that Maidana
fight like I remember watching the first
way down if I was that's the way you do
it you go after and then when I watch
the replay of the first Maidana fight he
caught flame Floyd legitimately once and
a lot of it was to the body he was I
mean and in the second fight obviously
he was totally outclassed um you know
Conor McGregor is this gonna be where
we're sitting there we're all excited
we're eating our popcorn we're eating
our chicken wings are eating our pizza
and then it starts there's a national
anthem
you know everybody's going to be you
know who in and on and then is it gonna
be boring twelve rounds of a normal
Floyd Mayweather fight cuz normally his
fights even when he's
most impressive they're boring or is it
gonna be I mean you really think that he
has the power at this at this age with
that weak hands cuz his hands are
they've been broken Elijah do you think
he has a chance to knock him out or I
mean like what are you like at the end
of the night Saturday I was speaking
about this a couple days ago I said as a
boxer strictly a boxer don't come
forward type of fighter if it ain't
broken don't fix it so I don't think I
mean you could say as much as you want
yeah I'm gonna attack I'm gonna do this
I'm gonna do that actions speak louder
than words
I don't really say oh I'm gonna attack I
just say hey it's gonna be a great fight
right we're gonna suit you know we're up
to I fought a couple weeks ago hey the
guy said he's gonna knock you out he's
gonna take it to you that you're weak
you're you have no heart you're gutless
okay that's cool well I see you saturday
or sunday night right well he said he's
gonna drop you I'm like you said that
already
great who cares right I'll see you
Sunday right we get in the ring on
Sunday and I was like all right and then
three rounds in I heard him completely
about on the virgin's to drop it and
stopping them fourth round the end
completely and I didn't have to really
sit there and say it I just I just boxed
I just did it all right well you're 30
years old I want to keep seeing you
doing your thing yeah there's I think
there's a lot a lot of in front of you
prediction give me what's gonna happen
Saturday who wins and how what's the
page I strongly believe like you had to
bet your tie collection like that's kind
of come on bro
it's a low blow okay I'm just kidding no
so I strongly believe like you were
saying earlier pushing for the boxer
because it is my sport I think he can
end it whenever he wants personally all
right whether it's early lay is this
really up to the momentum Floyd brings
all right Victor Ortiz thank you for
joining us thank you and you know it's
gonna be a fun night if nothing else
Saturday night and I appreciate you
joining the Rich Eisen show guest hosted
by me Michael Rapaport incredibly
dressed Victor Ortiz incredibly just
Michael Rapaport stay tuned we will be
right back legend a legend allegedly
very
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like that
please download our app there's lots of
fun things there other than just more of
the videos you just saw you can call us
from the app you can email us from the
app just download it trust me you'll
enjoy